Justin Jarrett
I have a really great memory of a guy called Bill Dowling out at Gumble.
He was an 89-year-old farmer and the Gumble Creek ran past his farm.
It was salty, the fish had died and there were no trees left on the banks of it.
And he stood next to me in tears and said: I caused this. And I've got that memory
etched in my mind forever, and I will not stand next to someone when I’m 89
and say: I caused this.
I want to be the person who stands there and says:
look at this, we improved it.
Now it's not easy, and it hurts at times, because you do things that you know aren't
going to make any money, and it is nice to have, you know, some luxuries.
But Pip and I want to be those people who can stand there and say: yep, we've
left this in better condition than what we got it.